Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Et voilà, vingt épisodes, on y est. C'est passé à une vitesse incroyable.
J'ai l'impression d'avoir démarré ce podcast genre hier.
Et pour célébrer cette milestone, un invité exceptionnel puisque je reçois cette semaine le magnifique Hugues Dayez, avec qui on a parlé des shifts importants que connaît en ce moment l'industrie du cinéma, mais pas seulement,
puisqu'on a aussi parlé de son fils qui est autiste Asperger et de la situation que Hugues connaît en tant que parent.
Comme vous le savez, c'est un sujet qui me tient particulièrement à cœur. Et on a aussi parlé du nombrilisme français, puisque voilà, il y a rien à faire, j'aime toujours autant quand ça tape sur la France dans ce podcast.
Il y aura aussi un paquet d'annonces hyper chouettes à la fin de cet épisode, donc restez bien jusqu'au bout. On retrouve tout de suite Hugues Dayez.
C'est parti. Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, nous sommes avec Hugues Dayez. Hugues Dayez, bonjour.
Bonjour Guillaume, bonjour à tous.
Hugues, tu es critique cinéma pour la RTBF depuis une trentaine d'années maintenant, c'est juste ?
Il y a eu des éclipses, ce serait un peu long à résumer, mais disons que je suis full time, en tout cas, cinéma depuis une bonne quinzaine d'années. Avant ça…
D'accord.
Mais par contre, l'émission Cinq Heures dans laquelle j'interviens va fêter sa vingt-cinquième saison. Donc, on peut dire que j'ai quand même vingt-cinq ans de critique cinéma au compteur.
Vingt-cinq ans de bouteilles au moins.
Parlons de ça, oui.
Question chiante qu'on te pose certainement trop souvent.
Combien de films je vois par semaine ?
C'est exactement la question que j'avais notée en premier.
Ah, c'est très variable. Pas tellement en fait. Je dirais une moyenne de six, parce qu'il y a des jours où je n'en vois pas du tout.
Parce qu'il y a des jours où je suis coincé en studio, en montage, en train de faire les émissions et donc je loupe ces,
ces jours-là, parfois deux, voire trois visions de presse, puisque il y a des jours, il peut y avoir des visions à dix heures,
à midi et à quatorze heures.
Ce qui est une mode assez récente, c'est qu'on n'a même plus le temps de bouffer, donc on cale des visions à midi.
Et puis parfois, il y a des jours où il n'y en a pas du tout. Donc, il y a parfois des semaines où j'en vois dix, des semaines où j'en vois quatre, mais disons que j'ai une moyenne de six.
À côté de ça, le soir, je regarde régulièrement des séries ou des anciens films que je revois par plaisir ou que je n'ai pas vus et que je tiens à voir pour élargir le champ et pour compléter ma culture.
Donc, je dirais qu'il y a des jours où je vois deux films dans la journée, puis encore deux à trois heures d'images le soir.
Quand tu dis six films par semaine plus une série Netflix de manière semi-régulière, voilà, le soir de temps en temps, c'est impressionnant, c'est même presque un peu flippant.
Comment est-ce que t'expliques cette capacité à ne pas te lasser de l'écran ?
Mais il y a des journalistes qui font beaucoup plus. Il y a des journalistes, par exemple, au Festival de Cannes, qui voient cinq films par jour.
Sur dix jours, ils en ont vu soixante. Et résultat, ils ont engrangé, ils ont pris des notes et ils ont engrangé, je dis pas pour toute leur saison, mais il y a des gens qui peuvent effectivement passer d'un film à l'autre.
Moi, après trois films, je sature, et j'ai besoin de retourner dans la vraie vie, de voir quel temps il fait.
Je ne peux pas exclusivement me réfugier dans la fiction. Néanmoins, ça reste beaucoup.
Mais c'est vrai que les jours où j'en vois trois, où je quitte le domicile ou le bureau à vélo à neuf heures et demie pour m'engouffrer dans une salle à dix heures et puis que j'ai juste le temps de,
ben en gros, de satisfaire un besoin naturel ou d'aller chercher un mini sandwich entre deux visions et puis,
puis que j'en sors à seize heures ou seize heures trente et en hiver où quelque part, on est entré dans la salle quand le matin commençait, la lumière commençait à poindre et qu'on ressort quand la lumière commence à tomber.
Je pense toujours aux gens qui travaillent dans des centres commerciaux qui ne voient pas la lumière du jour. Moi, je deviendrais complètement fou, vu que je suis très, très, très sensible à,
pas au fait qu'il fasse chaud ou beau, mais au fait qu'il y ait de la lumière.
Je suis très, très, très sensible à la lumière.
C'est presque la situation des personnes qui travaillent dans un centre commercial. Tu arrives et de suite, le soleil se lève, tu ressors, le soleil se couche.
Voilà, en hiver, en tout cas.
En fait, tu deviens fou. C'est un fait.
En hiver, en tout cas, c'est la situation que je traverse. Quand les films sont intéressants, c'est très bien.
C'est très, très, très variable. Il y a des journées qui sont pénibles parce qu'on a enchaîné un film ennuyeux, puis un film complètement raté, puis un navet total.
Et on se dit : j'ai perdu mon temps.
Et alors, dans ces cas-là, je me dis, ben toujours, je perds finalement moins mon temps que certains journalistes politiques qui sont…
dont on considère qu'ils font un métier plus sérieux parce qu'ils sont journalistes politiques et qu'ils ont attendu devant le seize, rue de la Loi pendant
deux, voire trois heures
qu'une berline sorte, avec des vitres fumées et que le type dise : pas de commentaire.
Là, j'estimerais ma journée totalement perdue. Moi, je dis toujours, même quand je vois un mauvais film, même si c'est pénible, ça m'en dit beaucoup sur l'époque.
D'accord.
On a le cinéma qu'on mérite et voir les modes, ce qui est à la mode, ce qui ne l'est plus, voir les tendances, voir ce dans quoi on s'engouffre, voir pourquoi on fait tel biopic, pourquoi on fait tel remake…
Tu penses à quoi, par exemple, quand tu évoques une daube, mais qui est une daube emblématique, symptomatique de notre époque ?
Ben là, on est en train de se rencontrer au moment où Canet sort Nous finirons ensemble, la suite des Petits Mouchoirs.
Ben là, on se rend compte que quelque part, ce que j'avais dit au moment du premier, qui avait été mal pris, en disant que pour moi, le film était assez révoltant parce que ne parlait jamais que de,
de problèmes de gens qui n'ont pas de problèmes, en fait.
C'est ça, c'est qu'on essayait de nous faire passer pour des problèmes existentiels. Des Parisiens extrêmement nantis, ben qui avaient effectivement le deuil d'un ami.
Bon, dans celui-ci, c'est encore pire. C'est-à-dire qu'ils continuent à être très nantis, mais le vrai problème, c'est,
c'est François Cluzet qui, oh là là, va peut-être devoir vendre sa maison au bord de la mer parce qu'il a des problèmes avec sa société et qu'il a fait des mauvais investissements.
On a envie de dire : Mais on s'en fout.
Problème de riches.
On s'en fout. Et le film, aujourd'hui, 'fin, dans le contexte aujourd'hui, est très très indécent. Je veux dire, la France est presque à feu et à sang.
Je pense qu'il est assez inconscient de faire des films comme ça aujourd'hui, parce que quand on voit la baraque de Canet au bord de la mer, on se dit : Mais pfff, c'est terrifiant.
Je veux dire, de nouveau, le syndrome nouveau riche est terrifiant. Alors, pour moi, on peut faire du cinéma de riches, y a absolument aucun problème.
Il est évident que Downton Abbey, d'une certaine façon, c'est des problèmes de nobles qui ont un grand château et c'est une série qui a passionné le monde entier.
Mais pourquoi ? Parce que, ben, il y a un contrepoint, c'est-à-dire qu'on s'intéresse autant à la vie des domestiques qu'à la vie des nobles en train de perdre leurs prérogatives et leur pouvoir au lendemain de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Il y a un vrai propos de la part de Julian Fellowes, qui écrit Downton Abbey. C'est pas uniquement une sitcom avec des gens qui sont nés avec une petite cuillère dans la bouche.
C'est beaucoup plus intéressant que ça au niveau de l'analyse sociale. Donc, y a aucun problème.
On peut évidemment, au cinéma, traiter tous les milieux,
mais alors, il faut vraiment qu'on les traite. Et le problème d'un film comme le film de Canet aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on est dans l'entre-soi,
c'est qu'on est dans, j'ai envie de dire, ben c'est une réunion de copains, mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a placé une caméra là ?
On pouvait les laisser entre eux. C'est pas du tout nécessaire que leurs problèmes, qui n'ont rigoureusement aucun intérêt, soient exposés en long et en large pendant deux heures quart.
Attention, je suis pas en train de dire que je ne veux que du cinéma social à la Ken Loach, parce que justement, je suis plutôt en train de dire qu'aujourd'hui, Ken Loach file un mauvais coton et fait du cinéma où la politique prime sur le cinéma.
Il y a beaucoup plus de politique que de cinéma dans ses derniers films qui sont manichéens et qui sont truffés de clichés, alors qu'il a fait des choses beaucoup plus vibrantes et beaucoup plus subtiles.
Donc, j'aime tous les types de cinéma, pour autant qu'ils soient bien écrits, bien écrits, avec un regard, avec une subtilité et idéalement, idéalement,
un peu d'ironie et de second degré, parce que je pense que sans l'ironie et le second degré, en 2019, on se tire une balle, c'est pas possible.
On va clore cette petite
parenthèse sur, voilà, le cinéma français. Il me semblait avoir vu, il y a quelques années, un article, un sondage qui montrait qu'un Belge francophone sur deux ou quoi,
voulait connaître l'avis de Hugues Dayez avant d'aller en salle de cinéma.
Ça, c'est un facteur de notoriété. C'est-à-dire que c'est effectivement une enquête très sérieuse. Et de mémoire, c'était plutôt 42 % et le deuxième avait 2 %.
C'est un score un peu stalinien. Ça vient d'où ? Ben ça vient du fait que je suis sur des médias de service public, mais donc très largement diffusés.
Quand je fais une séquence au journal télévisé, c'est quatre cent mille spectateurs minimum. Quand j'interviens sur La Première, c'est cent mille ou deux cent mille spectateurs, auditeurs, pardon.
Je ne connais pas et je ne connaîtrai jamais les scores de 5 heures, vu que c'est apparemment extrêmement difficile à quantifier.
Mais donc, il y a la télé, il y a la radio et depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années, facilement, il y a le Web, avec une des critiques écrites sur le Web toutes les semaines.
Donc, je travaille sur trois médias différents et qui, en plus, sont des médias de large diffusion. Ben, par la force des choses, il y a une espèce de suprématie par le nombre.
Il est évident que si je m'adresse à autant de monde, ben il y a beaucoup de gens qui, spontanément, si on va leur demander un nom de critique, vont citer Hugues Dayez plus facilement que,
je dirais au hasard, mon ami Fernand Denis ou Alain Lefèvre, qui travaillent dans La Libre Cinéma,
qui est un média, bon, tout le monde connaît les problèmes de la presse écrite.
Déjà, La Libre ne se porte pas très bien, mais qui, en plus, va systématiquement lire La Libre Cinéma le mercredi. Bon amusement.
Donc, forcément, j'ai envie de dire, l'échantillon de base de départ…
C'est une question de distribution quoi.
C'est une question… d'abord, et, ben, cela dit, il est évident que si je passais ma semaine, chaque semaine à dire : « Oh, à vous de juger.
Oh oui, ben écoutez, libre à vous et on en pense ce qu'on en veut » et que je n'émettais pas d'avis véritables, je pense effectivement que j'aurais pas émergé.
J'ai émergé parce que, dans un média de large diffusion, effectivement, je peux apparaître par certains comme lapidaire, mais disons que j'essaye très, très, très, très franchement d'avoir une vision et d'avoir un avis.
Je constate qu'il y a énormément de gens dans cette profession qui n'ont plus de vision, c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont voir un film et puis ils attendent de voir un petit peu ce que les autres en pensent.
Et puis on leur a surtout promis une interview de machin. Mais quand vous lisez ce qu'ils écrivent, il n'y a pas de point de vue, parce qu'ils sont viscéralement plus journalistes que critiques.
Et c'est pas de leur faute. C'est aussi, on a demandé à certaines personnes, certains confrères ou consœurs de s'improviser critiques très très rapidement.
Or, c'est un métier qui demande d'avoir énormément de substrat quoi. Il faut des couches de sédimentation. Moi, je me suis pas lancé critique immédiatement.
J'ai beaucoup observé. J'ai eu la chance de travailler pendant trois ans, quelque part comme seconde équipe, pour Sélim Sasson.
J'ai vu comment il travaillait. De temps en temps, à l'époque, Marcel Croës m'a confié des remplacements quand il ne pouvait pas assurer, mais j'ai avancé modestement, step by step.
Et c'est comme ça. Et simplement, j'avais, avant de commencer, déjà vu énormément de films. Aujourd'hui, si vous demandez à un type : Oh ben, tu as le temps ?
Oh, tu as quand même le temps d'aller voir ce film et en plus, tu te débrouilles en anglais, donc tu peux aller à l'interview.
Ce sont des mauvaises raisons. Il faut pas bombarder des jeunes confrères comme ça critiques parce que comment voulez-vous qu'ils attrapent une crédibilité, une assise ?
Moi, ça me paraît être… C'est un métier où il faut vraiment avancer lentement, mais sûrement quoi. Moi, je me souviens de ma toute première interview, c'était avec Charlotte Rampling.
J'étais proprement calamiteux, j'étais intimidé, j'ai quasi perdu mes moyens.
Donc ma notoriété, je dirais, il y a la surface de visibilité, il y a le fait que je fais ça depuis longtemps, il y a le fait que j'ai jamais dévié de ma ligne.
Quand je dis dévier de ma ligne, c'est ne pas céder aux modes.
Tu penses à quoi ?
Oh, je pense à Tarantino que je n'ai jamais mis sur un piédestal, parce que pour moi, c'est un cinéaste qui est,
qui est, pas un plagiaire, mais c'est une sorte de DJ qui mixe des films d'auteurs précédents et qui, c'est une sorte de…
Il aime les vieux Far West, alors il fait un Far West.
C'est une sorte de David Guetta de la création quoi. C'est, il prend des choses qui marchent et qui existent et puis il les revisite.
Il y a parfois un talent de dialoguiste évident, mais à côté de ça, il y a toujours le refuge dans du pif, pif, pouf, pouf, bam, bam, explosion.
Je trouve le scénario personnellement de Inglourious Basterds parfaitement débile. C'est pas pour rien que c'était produit par Harvey Weinstein.
C'est la revanche des Juifs sur les nazis. C'est une revanche fantasmée des Juifs sur les nazis, Inglourious Basterds.
Il s'assied sur la vérité historique. Bon, pas ça encore, mais c'est puéril, ce scénario. C'est complètement puéril. C'est sauvé par de la mise en scène, mais c'est puéril.
Et puis, ben à la limite, c'est les douze salopards quoi, c'est Dirty Dozen revu et corrigé.
C'est jamais quelqu'un qui crée au premier degré, enfin, qui crée à partir de rien, qui crée à partir d'un univers qui…
Mais donc, je note deux choses. D'une part, tu ne vois pas en lui un créateur.
Non.
Tu ne vois pas quelque chose, un projet original.
Et d'autre part, tu juges ça comme puéril.
Kill Bill, c'est assez puéril aussi. Il va prendre David Carradine parce qu'il l'a vu dans Kung Fu, dans la série Kung Fu.
Il a toujours le chic pour aller rechercher des comédiens qu'on avait oubliés. Ça, c'est très malin. Je crois qu'il y a un vrai amour du cinéma chez lui.
Il y a un vrai savoir-faire,
mais pour moi, on n'est pas au niveau de créateur de monde comme l'était Stanley Kubrick ou, ou même dans une moindre mesure, même s'il a un peu bousillé sa carrière, comme Lynch, qui a été un créateur de monde.
Voilà, il y a des gens qui sont vraiment créateurs de monde et puis des gens qui sont des bons, qui font du bon copier-coller.
Mais donc quand j'entends ces deux points, ça pose un petit peu la question de la subjectivité du critique cinéma…
Oui.
Qui va, voilà, entre guillemets, parler
depuis sa fenêtre. Et à côté de ça, ben il y a un jeune de seize ans qui va aller voir le dernier Tarantino et lui sera sans doute absolument pas dérangé ni par le manque d'originalité, ni par le côté puéril.
Oui, oui, mais ça, c'est le rôle des critiques. Ceux qui suivent les critiques, c'est de toute façon généralement pas tellement les spectateurs de seize ans et c'est normal.
Ils suivront des critiques, à mon avis, un peu plus tard ou peut-être jamais, mais moi, à seize ans, je suis, enfin…
À seize ans, je lisais des critiques, mais je veux dire, si j'ai envie d'aller voir un film, c'est pas un critique qui va m'empêcher d'aller le voir.
Et heureusement d'ailleurs, les distributeurs, les producteurs ont une peur bleue des critiques en se disant : Ils vont démolir le film et ils vont également démolir le box-office.
Aucun critique n'a jamais empêché personne d'aller voir envie,
d'aller voir un film s'il en a envie pour la simple et bonne raison que, si le marketing est bien fait, si les teasers sont bien foutus, si le film a été bien travaillé,
bon ou mauvais, les gens iront, parce qu'ils ont créé le désir pour aller le voir.
Et nous, moi, je pense que de toute façon, les gens qui suivent les critiques,
je sais pas, je peux pas les quantifier, mais je pense qu'il doit y avoir grand maximum 20 % des spectateurs qui vont en salle qui vont voir des critiques.
En riant, l'autre jour, je donnais une sorte de mini causerie et les gens me disaient : Oh, oh, vous faites la loi, vous faites la loi, de très mondains.
Et j'ai tout de suite cassé leurs effets en disant : Mais je fais peut-être la loi à l'UGC Toison d'Or, mais à De Brouckère, la loi, elle est déjà terminée.
Et en gros, c'était vrai, c'est-à-dire que je fais la loi auprès d'un public relativement, qui est un public qui lira aussi La Libre Cinéma pour…
Qui est un public de culture quoi.
Oui, non, et qui aime savoir ce qu'il faut aller voir. Voilà, ça, c'est la seule… enfin, quand on me dit : Et qu'est-ce qu'il faut aller voir ?
Je dis : Mais il ne faut rien aller voir. Je ne connais pas vos goûts. Dites-moi d'abord ce que vous allez voir en règle générale.
Alors, je vous aiguillerai, mais je vais pas… Mais alors, il y a des gens comme ça qui se disent : Il faut aller le voir.
Mais non, c'est ridicule. Il faut aller voir en fonction de son propre univers, de ses propres goûts, que ce soit littéraires, musicaux.
Je veux dire, on est dans une époque… Un des aspects que j'aime bien dans notre époque, c'est qu'on peut totalement se constituer sa bibliothèque idéale, sa filmothèque idéale.
On peut se constituer sa propre niche, sa propre, la tapisser absolument comme on veut. Alors qu'à une certaine époque, ben on était obligé de regarder le film du jeudi à vingt heures vingt ou vingt heures quinze.
Enfin, il y avait pas de pub, donc même vingt heures cinq. Et on n'avait pas le choix. C'était ça et pas autrement. Maintenant…
Donc si je comprends bien, les campagnes marketing, les campagnes publicitaires et le critique cinéma s'adressent à deux publics différents.
Oui. Mais moi, je fais un métier qui va disparaître de toute façon.
Ah, ça, c'est intéressant. Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire ?
Oui, parce que de toute façon, l'économie du cinéma va complètement changer.
À cause du streaming, à cause de Netflix ?
Moi, je pense que dans un avenir très, très, très, très proche. Je parle de dix ans, hein, maximum.
À partir du moment où on voit qu'un groupe Disney a vingt-sept pour cent de l'industrie du divertissement, à partir du moment où vous avez Avengers qui fait un milliard de recettes en cinq jours,
vous allez avoir au cinéma un univers de marques.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va exclusivement avoir une déclinaison de marques. La marque, ça peut être Disney, la marque, ça peut être Marvel, la marque, ça peut être Avengers un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq, la marque, ça peut être
Star Wars un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq, la marque, ça peut être le nouveau Pixar, la marque-- voilà.
Donc une déclinaison de marques qui marche mondialement et instantanément. Ça, ces films-là vont toujours faire le plein.
Ils peuvent se planter, il peut y avoir des accidents industriels, mais juste cette économie-là va fonctionner de mieux en mieux.
Et alors, ce qui se passe déjà, c'est que tout ce qui est plus pointu sur un marché plus spécifique va aller effectivement, pas forcément sur Netflix, mais sur les plateformes.
Ou alors chez des exploitants extrêmement, qui développent une formule club, on irait au cinéma presque comme on irait à une première de théâtre, enfin, qui privilégie le côté extrêmement confidentiel.
Ça existe déjà à Londres avec, presque une sorte... on revient à une espèce de bar-fumoir, comme ça, on va voir des...
Ça évoque un peu les COD Live quand tu dis ça.
Ça évoque ce qui existe. Ça évoque le-- je ne sais pas si c'est le Curzon à Londres, mais ça existe. Il y a quelques petits cinémas avec des petites jauges.
On va voir des films d'auteurs contemporains, qui ont un public de niche, mais majoritairement, qu'est-ce qui-- moi, pour moi, le cinéma a déjà vécu son onze septembre, hein.
C'est le jour où Roma, de Cuarón, a gagné le Lion d'or à la Mostra de Venise. Ce jour-là, Netflix avait non seulement le pognon et les abonnés, mais Netflix a gagné le prestige.
Et ce prestige n'a fait que s'accroître entre début septembre, Lion d'or pour Roma de Cuarón et Oscar du meilleur réalisateur pour Cuarón.
Il n'a pas eu meilleur film parce qu'il y a eu quand même de la résistance, mais il est reparti avec trois Oscars.
Donc à partir de ce moment-là, à partir du moment où Netflix est arrivé comme un cheval de Troie, mais derrière Netflix, il y a Hulu, il y a Amazon, il y a...
Voilà, donc je pense qu'il y a énormément de cinéastes. Aujourd'hui, on dit : Tiens, Scorsese va sur Netflix. Les frères Coen vont sur Netflix.
Mais oui, mais pourquoi ? Parce que ces cinéastes ne marchent plus en salle. Ça ne marche plus. Les derniers films de Scorsese.
Scorsese a longtemps eu un sponsor qui était Leonardo DiCaprio, qui l'a aidé à faire les films, à continuer à faire du cinéma.
Mais Scorsese n'est plus une valeur bankable. Donc voilà, et je crois qu'il y a énormément d'auteurs qui vont se réfugier.
Il y a le format des séries qui n'est pas uniquement un effet de mode, qui a changé même totalement la consommation des images.
Non seulement les gens ne vont plus au cinéma, mais les gens ne regardent plus du cinéma chez eux. Ils regardent des séries parce qu'avec cinquante-deux minutes, voire parfois vingt-six, ils ont leur dose de fiction.
C'est-à-dire que je me mets à la place d'un couple de trentenaires avec des enfants en bas âge qui sont curieux de culture.
Une fois que les gosses sont couchés, qui sont complètement fatigués par leur journée et qu'ils ont envie de fiction, ils vont s'installer devant la télé et ils vont regarder une heure de... un épisode de série.
S'ils ont l'énergie, ils vont avoir un deuxième, mais ils vont plus se lancer chez eux à regarder un film de deux heures vingt en continu en une seule soirée.
Tout ça semble très pertinent quand on parle du shift des salles de cinéma vers le streaming, vers Netflix. Voilà, on sait ce qui s'est passé à Cannes, on connaît les relations un petit peu compliquées.
Oui, à Cannes, ce n'était pas un accident ponctuel. La tendance continue. Cannes est un festival du vingtième siècle, vingt-et-unième siècle.
Cannes est un festival, pour moi, totalement dépassé.
Cette transition est parfaitement claire et tu l'as bien décrite.
Là où je comprends moins, c'est quand tu fais le lien avec ton métier à toi et tu dis : Mon métier à moi, tu l'associes de près à la salle de cinéma.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va être encore éventuellement prescripteur en disant : Voilà, il y a tel film cette semaine sur les plateformes.
Le problème est que, enfin, je pense que les gens auront encore, enfin, toute une frange de public curieux aura encore besoin de prescripteurs et envie de prescripteurs.
Mais dans la mesure où il y a une immédiateté de l'offre et qu'il ne faut plus la démarche de sortir-
L'argent est déjà dans la poche de Netflix.
Et que de toute façon, tout est disponible tout de suite. Je pense qu'il y a toute une frange de public qui va essayer, tentée par curiosité elle-même,
dans l'interface, dans le paysage de Netflix ou de n'importe quelle plateforme, de dire : Oh, mais je tenterais bien ça, j'irais bien voir ça.
Et voilà, et je pense que surtout, quel média, quel média va encore consacrer des pages et des pages ? Voilà.
Donc moi, ce qu'on fait, enfin, ce que je fais déjà en télévision, les directeurs de télévision, les derniers directeurs avec lesquels j'ai discuté ici, qui étaient des Français,
Yves Bigot et un directeur de la rédaction qui était Christian Dehaire, qui m'ont tous les deux dit : Ce que tu fais est déjà infaisable en France.
Ce n'est plus possible, puisqu'en France, la télé, ce n'est que de la promo, puisqu'ils sont coproducteurs. Puisque c'est des films France 2 ou TF1, la seule info, c'est dire : Le film sort ce mercredi et allez-y.
C'est... Moi, j'essaie en télévision d'avoir d'abord un choix, un choix éditorial, d'avoir quand même des critiques, même si elles sont forcément beaucoup plus brèves qu'en radio.
Mais ce que je fais en télévision, ce qu'on fait Rudy et moi dans Cinq Heures, c'est totalement hors norme. Hors norme.
Il y a aucune chance. Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a des Français qui nous écoutent et qui nous podcastent ? Parce qu'il n'existe rien de tel en France.
Si, il existe Le Masque et la plume, que, honnêtement, je n'écoute jamais, parce que la moitié des effectifs, je sais ce qu'ils vont dire avant de les écouter.
Enfin, je ne suis pas du tout, du tout dans la même logique, surtout qu'en France, il y a une espèce de suprématie fatigante, de défense de ce cinéma d'auteur qui ne vaut plus tripette.
Une forme de protectionnisme ou une forme de-
Oui, et d'anti-américanisme primaire qui est horripilant. Voilà. Et donc, merci. Donc j'écoute pas ça.
Mais donc, je veux dire, il y a pas beaucoup d'émissions, de paroles et de débats. Je pense que ça se réduit comme une peau de chagrin.
Je dis ça sans amertume. Je dis simplement que l'époque évolue. Moi, je suis au contraire, je suis très très très... je connais ma chance, hein.
Chaque jour, quand je commence mon boulot, même s'il y a des jours où j'ai pas le courage parce que le menu des sorties m'excite pas, mais chaque jour, je connais ma chance.
Je sais quand même que c'est absolument formidable de pouvoir être entièrement dédicacé à une discipline, de pouvoir la creuser, de pouvoir continuer à lire des bouquins, à-
Tu dis ça sans amertume, mais avec quand même un petit peu de regret. On a le sentiment, par rapport à cette ancienne époque.
Je trouve que de l'époque actuelle, je l'ai dit, bon, par exemple, le fait, je trouve-- voyons les côtés positifs. Je trouve que c'est impossible de s'emmerder aujourd'hui.
C'est parfois d'ailleurs un petit problème parce qu'il y a plein de pédopsychiatres qui disent : un enfant qui s'ennuie, c'est bien parce que ça va le forcer justement à sortir de l'ennui et à créer.
Ce qui est très vrai. Et c'est vrai que des enfants qui sont toute la journée devant un écran, c'est pas idéal. Là, je parle en tant qu'adulte, en tant qu'homme de cinquante-cinq ans.
Je me dis : c'est formidable parce que je ne dois plus jamais regarder la télévision. Je n'achète plus de programmes de télévision depuis dix ans.
Je ne sais même plus ce qui s'y passe. Et la télévision n'est qu'un moniteur,
n'est qu'un écran pour effectivement regarder soit des séries en streaming, soit, puisque je suis encore attaché à l'objet, soit des DVD de films qui m'intéressent.
Et ça, je trouve que c'est un luxe formidable. Là où c'est plus problématique, c'est cette espèce de consumérisme et de peur du vide que je trouve terrifiante.
Il y a dix fois trop de films, dix fois trop de bouquins, dix fois trop de bandes dessinées et tous les distributeurs disent : oui.
Même en Belgique, je veux dire, on n'est pas dans la situation de Paris, mais en Belgique, quand on a des semaines, on a huit ou dix sorties, alors que le Belge moyen va, je crois, deux fois et demi au cinéma par an.
C'est absurde, c'est ridicule. Et parfois, j'ai l'outrecuidance de dire : ce film ne doit pas sortir. Ce film n'est pas mûr, n'a aucun public potentiel.
C'est une sorte de fade petit téléfilm qui est en fait un film carte de visite. C'est un film pour les festivals, pour que le réalisateur puisse rencontrer des professionnels et dise : regardez, je suis quand même capable de faire un film.
Et : ah oui, tiens, on va regarder. C'est ça. Mais il y a beaucoup de-- j'ai envie de dire qu'en télévision, il y a ce qu'on appelait les numéros zéro, hein, les émissions test pour voir si l'émission tient debout.
Mais aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup de films zéro. Il y a beaucoup de films zéro qui sont des films. Mais comme il a quand même coûté, comme le producteur l'a quand même dans son catalogue, ben le producteur dit : on va le sortir.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Ben on fait une petite avant-première avec un petit média partenaire et complice. On a trois cent personnes dans la salle qui ont, qui sont venues gratuitement, qui applaudissent parce que c'était gratuit et qu'ils ont une coupe de champagne.
Et alors le réalisateur, il se dit : ah formidable. Et il y a des médias complices aussi. Comme c'est un film belge, on va faire deux pages dans le supplément culturel et interviewer le réalisateur et l'actrice.
Tu comprends, c'est belge. Je dis : mais non, je ne comprends pas. Le film est mauvais, il n'a aucun intérêt. Il n'y a aucune raison de donner une surface d'exposition et de visibilité à un film qui, de toute façon, va sortir sur cinq copies,
va faire cinq cent spectateurs, si tout va bien, et va être balayé de l'affiche après trois jours.
Et c'est un très très très mauvais service à rendre au réalisateur, parce que le réalisateur, le mardi soir, il se dit : ah, formidable, j'ai eu deux pages dans tel média et j'ai eu une avant-première et les gens ont applaudi.
Mais forcément, il n'est pas dans la vraie vie. La vraie vie, c'est le mercredi, une fois que le film sort.
C'est un peu un égotrip, tout ça, quand tu décris ça comme ça.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est ça. On soigne un égotrip et on soigne l'entre-soi, on soigne-- et c'est très très, et ça, c'est très-
C'est très malsain.
Oui, mais oui, bien sûr. C'est-à-dire que depuis que le cinéma belge, grosso modo, gagne dans les festivals, depuis qu'il y a les Magritte, il y a une espèce d'autocensure comme ça de la profession.
C'est belge, donc c'est bien.
Ouais.
Moi, je dis : mais il faut arrêter tout de suite.
Le chauvinisme français qui passe un petit peu par chez nous.
Et je dis au contraire, c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où le cinéma belge joue dans la cour des grands, où effectivement, il gagne des prix dans des festivals, où il est sélectionné dans--, eh bien,
à partir du moment où il se met dans la cour des grands, il doit être traité comme un grand et plus avec du patronizing, quoi, plus avec cette espèce d'attitude positivement
complaisante, comme ça, de dire : c'est quand même belge, on va l'aider.
Et j'ai des discussions infinies avec certains confrères me dire : oui, mais quand même, le pauvre. Je dis : mais le pauvre, personne ne l'a demandé, personne ne l'a forcé.
Et je dis en plus, secundo, je dis : OK. Souvent, fin du débat, fin de la discussion, on me dit : c'est quand même une jolie proposition de cinéma.
Je dis : OK. Tu sortirais de chez toi ? Tu payerais dix euros pour aller le voir ? Oh non, non, naturellement. Je dis : ben voilà, commence par te poser cette question-là.
Moi, je me mets toujours à la place du public qui paye sa place et jamais à la place du producteur. Et ce qui me vaut évidemment une réputation de tueur, de fossoyeur, de tout ce qu'on veut.
Mais à côté de ça, à partir du moment où Girl, dès le début, je me dis : waouh, on est devant un vrai cinéaste. On a accompagné Girl, du mois de mai jusqu'à la sortie en octobre.
Pourquoi est-ce que Lukas Dhont a accepté de venir faire un podcast spécial d'Une Heure K là où il était déjà à faire des interviews d'un quart d'heure à la chaîne ?
Parce qu'à ce moment-là, il était très demandé. Mais parce qu'il a senti qu'il y avait un vrai soutien, un vrai enthousiasme, une vraie envie de travailler sur le film avec lui.
Donc voilà, je suis pas systématiquement fossoyeur du cinéma belge, arrêtons tout de suite. Bref, je suis effectivement fossoyeur du cinéma quand je le trouve indigne de sortir en salle.
Indigne de sortir en salle, voilà.
Mais c'est intéressant qu'on touche un petit peu
aux coulisses du cinéma, à la production. Quand on parle des projets qui se montent ici en Belgique, un mot qui revient souvent, ou deux mots quand on parle de la Belgique, c'est le Tax Shelter.
Hugues, est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est, le Tax Shelter ?
Ben, le Tax Shelter, c'est un mécanisme qui permet à des boîtes privées, si elles investissent dans la production d'un film, d'avoir une exonération fiscale des montants investis.
Je ne sais pas à quel ordre de-- à quel pourcentage. Je sais qu'on parlait de mon excellent confrère Alain Lorfève, qui a vraiment se pencher sur la question de manière beaucoup plus sérieuse que moi.
Moi, j'ai arrêté mes études d'économie, c'était pas pour m'y replonger dedans à cent pour cent. Le problème est que le Tax Shelter, comme d'habitude, il y avait le ver dans le fruit.
C'est qu'il y a des producteurs honnêtes et authentiquement cinéphiles qui en ont profité pour monter des projets plus ambitieux,
pour faire des coproductions sérieuses avec la France en attirant des investisseurs français en disant : Regardez comme c'est intéressant.
Bon très bien, parfait. Et à côté de ça, il y a des boîtes de marchands de soupe.
Littéralement, ouais.
Des types qui n'en ont rien à foutre du cinéma, mais qui se sont dit : Là, il y a du pognon à prendre.
Et c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont monté de toutes pièces une boîte de production de films en prenant n'importe quel projet, tant qu'il n'était pas trop cher.
On pouvait éventuellement embarquer
une starlette au générique. Donc la starlette attire éventuellement le fabricant de saucisson qui se dit : C'est formidable, je vais pouvoir aller un jour sur le tournage et voir, serrer la main de la starlette et faire des selfies.
Je caricature à peine, hein, et on aura une avant-première avec une salle réservée pour nous. Je pourrai inviter tous mes clients, tous mes mangeurs de saucisson à éventuellement aussi faire une photo avec la starlette.
Et ces films-là sont montés pour des mauvaises raisons. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a aucune-- à aucun moment, on ne s'intéresse à la qualité du scénario et à la qualité de la mise en scène.
On monte un projet et en fait, tout le monde se sert avant même que le film sorte en salle. C'est-à-dire que le producteur prend sa part, le réalisateur prend sa part.
Généralement, bon le producteur s'arrange et le monteur du projet, qui a mis tout ça sur pied, s'arrange évidemment pour se servir très confortablement.
Et résultat des courses, le film sort, il fait un bide public, mais ça n'a aucune importance puisque c'est une sorte d'opération blanche.
Bon, on sait qu'aujourd'hui, le Tax Shelter, il y a eu tellement d'abus, il y a eu des malversations comptables.
On a fait-- y a un filou qui a fait semblant que tel argent sur tel film, mais finalement, le film ne se faisait pas.
Il a fait semblant qu'il avait été dévié sur un autre film d'animation. Enfin, il y a eu tout un,
un gros scandale et, résultat des courses, on-- je sais que les pouvoirs publics essayent de mettre de l'ordre dans tout ça aujourd'hui.
Et donc la mécanique commence à avoir des ratés. Et l'autre élément, c'est qu'il y a un côté miroir aux alouettes, si tu veux.
Parce qu'on a dit : Oh, la Belgique, c'est formidable. Les techniciens belges, c'est formidable. Ça fait vivre notre cinéma.
Et en fait, y a-- c'est pas moi qui l'ai dit, il y a un producteur qui m'a dit un jour : Tu sais, un jour où la Moldavie ou
n'importe quel petit pays d'Europe, c'est moins cher et c'est plus avantageux pour les Français, beh, toute cette bulle va se dégonfler et ils iront produire plutôt là. Donc moi,
tant mieux si certains projets ambitieux ont pu se faire grâce au Tax Shelter, mais je ne pleurerai certainement pas
la cargaison de navets innommables du style Boule et Bill un et deux qu'on a pu faire grâce à du Tax Shelter.
Oui, en plus, le nombre de films qui sont effectivement... Voilà, ça, c'est le prototype de films qui sont faits pour des mauvaises raisons.
Les adaptations de BD au cinéma, pourquoi elles se font ? Ben parce que le producteur se dit : C'est bien simple, la BD fait quoi ?
Cent mille, deux cent mille, trois cent mille lecteurs. Dans ces trois cent mille lecteurs, j'aurai peut-être déjà la moitié qui sont des spectateurs acquis à la cause et qui viendront voir le film par curiosité.
Mais c'est évidemment un calcul purement producteur et qui n'a rien d'artistique. Et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est tapé un déluge de trucs immondes, ces dernières années.
À un certain stade, on dit : Ça suffit. Je peux te faire la liste des trucs que j'ai vus, c'est à te dégoûter du cinéma.
C'est-à-dire y a rien de ciné-- y a pas une idée de cinéma là-dedans.
Le Tax Shelter, c'est seulement du côté belge francophone, 'fin, de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles ou bien c'est fédéral ?
Là, tu m'en poses une bonne grosse colle. Ils n'ont pas, ils n'ont pas-
Est-ce que les Flamands font des films Tax Shelter ?
Oui, oui.
C'est peut-être plus facile à répondre.
Oui, je pense. Oui, oui, oui, oui. En tout cas, bon, ils ont aussi ce guichet, ils ont le Vlamso du Risouphone.
La grosse différence, la grosse, la différence number one avec le cinéma flamand, c'est que contrairement à la Belgique qui a besoin des Français, les Flamands n'ont besoin de personne.
Ils n'ont pas besoin des Hollandais. Ils sont en autarcie. Non, mais ils sont en autarcie parce qu'ils ont développé ce qu'on appelle les Bekende Vlamingen.
Ils-- N'importe quelle Miss Météo, n'importe quel type qui fait du tirage du loto, il passe sur un tapis rouge, ça draine les foules.
Tu peux essayer un tapis rouge à n'importe quelle première en Belgique francophone, tout le monde s'en fout. Il y a absolument-- le star system ne fonctionne pas une seconde et c'est d'ailleurs extrêmement problématique.
Les producteurs s'arrachent les cheveux, ils disent : Bon. Si, il y a quelques acteurs belges qui sont un peu stars, uniquement parce qu'ils ont été reconnus en France.
Donc voilà. Donc la situation est totalement différente. En Flandre, quand tu vois les scores des films flamands,
des trucs comme des De Kampioenen, qui sont des espèces de sitcoms dérivées d'une série télé innommable, ça fait des cinq cent mille, six cent mille sur la moitié nord du pays.
Ça n'a même pas besoin-- ça ne sort pas sur tout le territoire. Alors qu'en francophonie, quand, enfin, on a le Wallonie plus Bruxelles, quand on arrive à faire cinquante mille, on sabre le champagne.
La seule exception récente, c'est,
c'est Damiens avec Mon Ket qui a fait, je crois, cent cinquante mille parce que c'est une comédie, parce qu'il est populaire, parce qu'il y a les caméras cachées, parce qu'il existe en France,
pour toutes ces raisons-là et parce que ça n'a pas été vu.
D'ailleurs, il a été traité avec mépris au Magritte. Ça n'a pas été vu comme du cinéma. Ça a été vu comme le nouveau happening de François Damiens.
Et il y a plein de gens qui n'iraient jamais au cinéma qui ont été le voir parce que c'était François Damiens. Mais sinon, en règle générale, les films francophones,
un film des frères Dardenne, je pense que quand il atteint septante mille spectateurs, le distributeur est content.
Donc c'est ces deux pays, ces deux mondes, ces deux mondes.
Ces deux mondes distincts, là, ce rapport à l'ego, ce rapport au star system, comment, ça, c'est peut-être un peu plus compliqué comme question, mais tu l'attribues à quoi, cette différence culturelle ?
Ben parce que les Flamands ont très très longtemps, historiquement, été dominés par la culture française. Les bourgeois, c'est ce qu'on appelait les...
Enfin oui, c'est, les bourgeois de Gand et d'Anvers parlaient français, même s'ils étaient nés en territoire flamand.
Les écrivains flamands écrivaient en français. Et donc il y a eu cette espèce de suprématie du français. Et maintenant, on a le retour du bâton.
Il y a eu une sorte de complexe qui s'est renversé. Et maintenant, les Flamands, leur première langue, c'est le flamand, leur deuxième langue, c'est l'anglais.
Ils passent... moi, je me souviens qu'enfant, je regardais la BRT, ancêtre de la VRT, la Belgisch et non pas la Vlaams, hein.
Et la VRT, tu avais Jo Rupke, qui était l'équivalent de Céline Sasson, qui est venue là se grapper que comédie, Ivan Patrice Lecomte, Les Bronzés font du ski, Maître Michel Blanc.
C'est fini, ça. Il y a plus un film français qui sort en Flandre, en tout cas pas une comédie. Ils en ont rien à foutre puisque leur deuxième langue, c'est l'anglais.
Et la moitié des cinéastes flamands, ils font un premier film en flamand et puis très très vite, ils font un film en anglais. Le deuxième film,
ils vont le tourner aux USA. Quand ils peuvent tourner le pilote d'une série ou n'importe quoi, dans le système hollywoodien, vite faire partie de la guilde des réalisateurs machin, mais
ils se sentent plus pisser, ils font des bons joints.
C'est effectivement quelque chose qui me frappe, moi, quand je regarde. Mais ça se voit dans le cinéma et ça se voit dans la musique aussi.
Tu vas voir un concert de Deus. Tu vois Tom Barman sur scène qui a un accent presque naturel américain et qui a des phrases, des intonations, où tu te dis : Mais il vient de New York, lui.
Ils sont biberonnés à ça. Regarde leur programme télévisé. Ils n'ont que les talk shows, ils ont les talk shows de Jeremy Norton qu'ils sous-titrent en flamand.
Ils ne bouffent que de l'anglo-saxon toute la journée. Et c'est pour ça qu'ils s'en sortent économiquement aussi. Parce qu'évidemment, tu penses bien quand un type,
un Felix van Groeningen ou un Michael Roskam va faire un film aux USA, bon ou mauvais, il est dans une autre économie et un autre système que le pauvre cinéaste belge qui attend toujours qu'un producteur français veuille bien coproduire son film.
Quand tu regardes ça, est-ce que tu te dis : Tiens, au fond, nous, du côté francophone, on devrait peut-être faire pareil ?
Ou bien est-ce que tu regardes ça en disant : Ben, c'est quand même très américanisé et ça perd un peu son authenticité.
Non, je pense que l'énorme problème, c'est qu'on soit à ce point accolé au cinéma français qui est un cinéma en décrépitude.
Il y a ce critique américain qui a dit : Il y a plus de nouveaux créateurs depuis Godard. Il s'est fait vouer aux gémonies, mais fais le compte.
Il y a pas grand monde. Il y a pas grand monde. Bon, Cannes va toujours dire qu'il y a Arnaud Desplechin et Olivier Assayas, mais ces gens-là sont inexportables, inexportables.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne parlent même pas le français, ils parlent le parisien. Déjà en province, leurs films ne marchent pas.
C'est-à-dire que c'est ce que j'appelle dans le podcast de Cinco régulièrement le triangle d'or Télérama, Rock, Libération.
Mais au-delà de ça, c'est insortable. Les films français, qu'on arrête de rire, il y a Unifrance qui se bombe le torse en disant : Cette année, on a fait des millions d'entrées.
Quand ils font des millions d'entrées, c'est généralement parce qu'ils ont eu une,
une Bessonerie, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont eu une production Luc Besson, un Taken un, deux ou trois, tourné en anglais avec un acteur américain et tourné éventuellement en Seine-Saint-Denis ou avec un presse-bouton français.
Mais c'est pas des films français, ça, c'est pas ça. Mais ça, c'est les films français exportables aujourd'hui.
Mais sinon, qu'est-ce que tu as comme film français ? Et donc le problème du cinéma belge, c'est qu'il est accolé à un système qui est obsolète.
Parce que le système de l'exception culturelle en France, c'est très joli, ça permet effectivement encore de produire deux cents films par an là où il y a énormément de pays où il y a plus rien ou très très peu de choses.
Mais quelle est la qualité et le potentiel de ces films ? Tu as soit des comédies qui puent du cul et qui sont inexportables façon Les Tuche un, deux ou trois ou qu'est-ce qu'on...
Enfin, on en a toutes les semaines, des Dubosc, des Kad Merad. Bon, ça fait le plein, ça fait un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq millions, parfois même jusqu'à des dix millions.
Mais c'est inexportable. Si, c'est un peu exportable en Belgique et en Suisse et au Canada. Mais c'est, une fois passée la barrière de la langue, c'est inexportable.
Pour revenir sur la comédie de Christian Clavier, là, Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au bon Dieu ? J'ai justement entendu que ça marchait assez bien en Allemagne et que ça s'exportait ailleurs en Europe.
Oui, mais les Allemands ont toujours eu un mauvais goût très sûr. Je veux dire, au niveau de la comédie, comme ils ne sont pas capables d'en faire eux-mêmes, je sais qu'ils ont sorti,
à peu près tous les films de Pierre Richard et ils étaient tous titrés Le Grand Blond machin. C'était jamais-
Oui, oui, tout à fait, des trucs comme ça.
Voilà. Il y a des trucs hallucinants.
Ça a le mauvais goût, mais ça marche.
Oui, enfin, c'est-
Est-ce qu'on peut vraiment leur dire ?
Marcher, mais, je veux dire, quand je parle international, c'est quand même marcher dans les pays qui pratiquent l'anglais ou l'américain, qui sont quand même les-
Mmm-hmm.
Les rois du monde aujourd'hui, quoi. Brexit ou pas Brexit, de toute façon, l'anglais restera ce qu'il est. Je vois pas une inversion de la tendance.
On va pas commencer à parler français pour, enfin, à ce que le français redevienne de la langue diplomatique.
Je pense qu'on peut pas revenir en arrière. Je pense que l'anglais restera très important. Et donc le drame du cinéma belge, au niveau de la production et des infrastructures, c'est qu'il se reste à ce point si,
si belge francophone, c'est qu'il se reste à ce point si accolé au cinéma français.
Parce que je pense vraiment que le jour où l'exception culturelle saute,
ce qui arrivera, parce que chaque année il faut tout le temps négocier auprès de la Commission européenne qui dit : C'est gentil, mais c'est quand même de la concurrence déloyale.
Ce que vous faites là d'injecter des subsides à tout crin dans une activité commerciale, puisque eux le voient comme une activité commerciale.
Jusqu'à quand on pourra prétendre que c'est une activité artistique si on sort des... si le cinéma français sort des Tuche et des films qui sont formatés pour TF1, pour le prime time de TF1 et pour les prime times de télévision.
Ces films-là, tu as suivi la fameuse tribune dans Le Monde de Maraval il y a quelques années, qui disait quand même que
même si le type avait une dose de mauvaise foi quand il disait qu'un acteur américain, dans un film indépendant américain était moins bien payé que Mimi Mathy ou qu'un-
Oui, oui, ça, oui, tout à fait.
Et les salaires indécents, indécents des acteurs français ne correspondent absolument plus à leur valeur sur le niveau international.
Et ces types se-- enfin tant mieux pour eux, ils auraient cet Take The Money and Run, ces prends le et tire-toi, ils auraient tort de ne pas en profiter si on le propose.
Mais c'est des cachets astronomiques pour des films qui ne marchent plus. Historiquement, je me souviens quand ça a commencé, je peux même te le dire, c'était un film qui a fait la clôture à Cannes, il y a très très très longtemps.
Ça s'appelait Toxic Affair, c'était de Philomène Esposito et ça devait relancer. C'était le grand retour d'Isabelle Adjani.
C'était une comédie innommablement mauvaise, c'était piteux. Et Adjani, ce qui avait fait scandale, c'est qu'elle avait touché un cachet de dix millions de francs français-
Mmm-hmm.
Pour cette petite comédie. Elle avait même pas osé se présenter à la conférence de presse à Cannes tellement le film avait été laminé.
La pauvre réalisatrice est Clémentine Célarié avait dû se démerder toute seule comme des grandes. Et à l'époque ça avait fait scandale.
Quoi ? Dix millions pour une petite comédie. Où est passé l'argent ? Mais je raconte ça, mais ce n'est que le début d'une inflation, mais absolument hallucinante de gens qui se servent, mais de façon,
totalement indécente par rapport à ce que le film fait en salle.
Que Dany Boon gagne de l'or en bas, quelle que soit la qualité de ses films, il y a une logique économique. Il fait des millions d'entrées.
Je veux dire, ils ne volent pas le pain qu'il mange, même s'il se sert à la fois comme acteur, comme scénariste, comme coscénariste, comme réalisateur, comme coproducteur.
Il sert à tous les postes. Ben, il est malin. Bon, mais en attendant... Bon, maintenant, je sais qu'il est un peu dans de sales draps parce qu'il est question d'évasion fiscale, mais au-delà de ça,
le type, il fait vingt millions d'entrées, il fait dix millions d'entrées, il fait six millions d'entrées.
Voilà, il creuse un filon, le comique provincial, du néo-Bourvil, naïf, gentil et familial et sans prétention.
Il creuse, il occupe un créneau. Très bien, parfait. Mais à côté de ça, des mecs qui se la pètent, qui font des films insortables et qui en plus, ne touchent plus terre et ont des prétentions salariales.
Là, on comprend le papier de Vincent Maraval, quoi.
Oui. Donc, je note d'une part ce malaise que tu as avec la production française en cinéma qui est en décalage avec son temps, avec le monde-
Oui.
Qui est un peu centrée sur elle-même, nombriliste. Et d'autre part, la transition, voilà, de la distribution des salles de cinéma vers le streaming et-
Ce que ça implique pour le journalisme. C'est deux transitions très intéressantes dont on a pu parler en long et en large.
Un point dont je souhaitais parler avec toi. J'ai fait un podcast, un Septante Minutes Avec spécial il y a un mois sur l'autisme.
Mmm-hmm.
L'autisme, c'est quelque chose que tu connais personnellement puisque tu as un fils, Thomas, qui est concerné directement, qui est autiste Asperger.
Première question que j'avais envie de te poser à ce sujet, c'est : Mais tiens, pourquoi est-ce que tu as fait le choix de parler de ça publiquement ?
Ah, parce qu'on me l'a demandé. D'abord, bon, j'en parle parce que j'ai pas de secret. Je trouve qu'il y a-- c'est pas honteux.
Il y a une certaine époque où des personnalités avaient un enfant handicapé, osaient à peine en parler, mais en même temps, j'en fais pas non plus des-
Des caisses.
Des caisses, non. Je crois que j'en ai parlé à deux reprises. J'en ai parlé au moment de Cap48, une année où effectivement, l'école, qui était une école pionnière, qui n'accueillait que des enfants Asperger, l'école,
créée maintenant, qui fête ses dix ans, l'école des Quatre Vents, ben cherchait des subsides.
Au départ, c'étaient les parents qui payaient pour cette école parce qu'elle n'était pas reconnue. Bref, hein. Et donc moi, étant parent d'un enfant dans cette école, c'était tout trouvé.
Le truc est, l'œuvre, l'école était bénéficiaire de Cap48. Ben, ça tombait sous le sens que j'allais quelque part être, entre guillemets, ambassadeur de cette cause-là lors de cette édition-là.
Et je n'ai pas remis le couvert chaque année. L'autre occasion, c'est effectivement l'été dernier, la sœur de François Damiens m'aborde et dit : Voilà, est-ce que tu connais Sam, etc.
? Je dis : Non, pas du tout. Voilà, on voudrait faire une campagne pour les aidants proches. Elle dit : Ah bon ? De quoi s'agit-il ?
Et... Elle dit : « Ben les aidants proches, c'est toi. C'est toi, ça peut être une sœur, un frère, enfin, c'est la famille.
C'est qui consacre ben une partie de son temps, qui a vu sa vie, son emploi du temps modifié de par le fait qu'il s'occupe.
» Il me dit : « Tu n'imagines pas à quel point ils sont nombreux en Belgique ». Et finalement, y a rien, on n'en parle jamais.
Je dis : Ben moi, si je peux effectivement mettre mon petit capital de notoriété au service de tous ces gens qui rament.
Et Dieu sait qu'il y en a qui rament hein parce que... Ben là, je suis encore allé, il y avait une petite fête pour les dix ans de l'école et on a revu tous les anciens.
Ben bon, moi, mon fils, il est casé. Enfin, il est casé, il fait une activité d'apprenti boulanger pendant trois jours par semaine dans une boulangerie spéciale qui est considérée comme un centre de jour. Donc, il s'occupe.
On le paye pour qu'il soit là, mais il apprend les codes sociaux, etc. Donc, il y a trois jours par semaine où il apprend la vie en société, deux jours par semaine où
il vit sa vie et deux jours par semaine où il fait des activités avec moi le week-end.
Donc sa vie est variée. J'estime que bon, je touche du bois, mais ça va. Je dis pas du tout qu'il est tiré d'affaire, mais en tout cas, il a un rythme de vie, il n'est pas livré à lui-même.
Quand je vois le nombre de parents qui rament, leur gosse est chez eux, ils rentrent dans aucune case, y a aucun job qui est possible parce que pour telle ou telle raison.
Donc je me dis : Moi, c'est ces gens-là qu'il faut aider. Effectivement, il faut aider les autistes ou les handicapés eux-mêmes, mais il faut aussi aider les,
les parents ou les, enfin les, oui, voilà, les aidants proches à trouver des sujets, parfois pouvoir trouver une échappatoire, des ASBL qui s'occupent d'organiser des vacances.
Moi, j'étais toujours tombé sur une formidable ASBL où il y avait sept ans, une liste d'attente de sept ans pour pouvoir inscrire le gamin dans des activités de groupe.
Après sept ans, ils nous ont recontactés. On dit : « C'est quoi ? » On avait complètement oublié qu'on était sur cette liste après sept ans.
Et malheureusement, ça n'a pas fonctionné. Ils étaient d'une totale bonne volonté, mais Thomas n'a pas voulu y rester.
Y a aussi le problème en Belgique, là, je déborde, mais c'est que, en fait, en Belgique, on est déjà beaucoup mieux lotis qu'en France-
Oui, c'est sûr.
Voilà. Mais souvent, les structures mêlent quelque part les trisomiques et les autistes.
Oui.
En se disant : Bon, on n'a pas de place, donc on va... Et en fait, c'est les Montaigu et les Capulets. En fait, comme je dis en riant, c'est Léo Timine, c'est Léo Ara dans un épisode de Lucky Luke où il y a deux familles.
Une famille avec des gros nez, une famille avec des grandes oreilles. Et ils se tapent sur la gueule pendant quarante-six pages.
C'est un album désopilant. Et moi, je dis toujours : Mais mettez les autistes et les trisomiques ensemble. Mais c'est de la folie parce que les trisomiques sont extrêmement affectueux dans le contact physique, dans la proximité, dans le...
Ouais, voilà, y a pas de sur moi, c'est vraiment... Et à côté de ça, les autistes sont au contraire dans la retenue, dans la distance.
Le contact physique peut être parfois extrêmement difficile et donc ils les voient arriver avec horreur. Et c'est un mélange, c'est l'huile et le feu.
Donc voilà, pour toutes ces raisons-là, et peut-être aussi parce que je suis viscéralement dans la critique, je suis journaliste, donc j'aime bien exposer des problèmes, synthétiser des situations.
Ça me paraissait l'occasion de synthétiser une situation problématique et qui pose question en Belgique. Voilà, point barre.
Mais à côté de ça, je veux dire, c'est vraiment avec beaucoup de parcimonie et beaucoup de modestie. Je suis fer de lance de rien du tout.
Je suis membre d'aucune association. Parce que c'est pas du tout que j'y crois pas, mais je n'ai pas l'énergie pour ça. Je suis admiratif de gens qui effectivement en font leur cause et la cause de leur vie.
Moi, c'est l'inverse, c'est-à-dire que le vivre... J'ai,
je vais faire une parenthèse, hein. Il y avait ce copain des proches qui s'appelle Jean-Louis Fournier, qui écrit
des livres formidables et très drôles sur ses enfants handicapés, enfin plein d'humour noir.
Et on me dit : « Tiens, pourquoi t'écris jamais ? Tu écris beaucoup. Pourquoi t'écris ? » Je dis : Parce que j'ai pas envie de...
Quand j'écris ou quand je fais quelque chose de créatif, c'est justement pour sortir de mes problèmes et absolument pas pour m'y replonger. Donc, voilà.
C'est intéressant parce que bon, on sait que l'autisme est un spectre.
Oui.
Certains disent : Il y a autant de formes d'autisme que de personnes autistes.
Oui, oui.
Ce que je remarque quand toi, tu en parles, c'est que tu l'évoques comme étant un de tes problèmes. Tu parles de handicap, tu fronces un peu les sourcils en en parlant.
Ça semble être une charge à porter.
Oui, parce que, enfin, il y a toujours l'énorme question qui a d'ailleurs été évoquée dans un des films de Van Dormael, c'est l'après.
On ne peut pas penser à l'après. Enfin, il faut y penser et en même temps, c'est notre cauchemar à nous, parents. Qu'est-ce qui va devenir ?
Déjà un enfant normal, on s'inquiète, mais un enfant qui n'est pas autonome.
On peut peut-être revenir sur la situation spécifique de ton fils. Comment est-ce que tu décrirais son autisme ?
Ben il n'est pas dans le réel. Il-
D'accord.
Il se débrouille admirablement. Tous les autistes Asperger, donc ce qu'on appelle les autistes de haut niveau parce qu'ils communiquent, ils parlent, ils ont une intelligence développée.
Ils ont tous, on dirait chez nous, ils ont tous des zines quoi, ils ont tous des obsessions. Il y en a qui peuvent être obsédés-- je parle d'exemples concrets parce que je l'ai vu, des condisciples de Thomas, etc.
Il y en a qui pouvaient être obsédés à dessiner des plans de ville toute la journée. Il y en a qui peuvent être obsédés par connaître tout sur la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Les plaques d'égout, etc.
Des plaques d'égout, des numéros d'immatriculation de trains. Bon-
Des intérêts spécifiques, on appelle ça.
Moi, mon-- des intérêts spécifiques. Moi, je dis carrément obsessionnels quoi. Et mon fils est obsédé par les contes de fées et les histoires sous toutes leurs formes.
Depuis qu'il est tout petit, il se réveillait très très très tôt et alors, honte sur moi, je ne sais pas, est-ce que c'est moi qui ai allumé la mèche, mais toujours est-il que je me réveillais très tôt aussi et j'allais lui mettre
une cassette, on choisissait ensemble et dès que la cassette était lancée, j'essayais d'aller me recoucher.
Bon, et donc il a été biberonné aux histoires de fiction. Le plus drôle, c'est qu'en grandissant, son choix s'est réduit, c'est-à-dire qu'il déteste les images de synthèse, il veut du dessin animé classique, il déteste les suites.
Enfin, quelque part, c'est une version autiste de moi hein, donc voilà.
Ça va à quelqu'un, ouais.
Mais donc il est obsédé par ça. Et alors le plus amusant, c'est que bon, il y a sept, huit ans maintenant, grâce à un ami animateur, j'ai acheté un programme informatique qui permet de faire des dessins animés soi-même.
Donc il a une palette graphique et il a un programme qui est un programme canadien formidable où il dessine. Et puis, il peut mettre le dessin qu'il vient de faire en très très léger, en très rose ou bleu clair.
Et puis donc, il a la mémoire du souvenir du dessin précédent. Au-dessus de ça, il peut faire le dessin suivant.
Et c'est le principe même du dessin animé. Avant, on faisait du flipping sur une feuille, on regardait le dessin précédent pour pouvoir avancer et faire le dessin suivant.
Bon, et lui, il a ça sur son écran. Et comme l'autiste n'a aucune espèce de lassitude par rapport au travail répétitif, il est plus productif que le studio Hanna-Barbera eux-mêmes.
Il fait des dessins animés au kilomètre. Il a totalement intégré le langage, il fait du champ, contrechamp, plan d'ensemble.
C'est de la sitcom. Et donc il fait des épisodes inédits de Schtroumpfs ou que sais-je, de Pinocchio. Il fait des mashups.
Il fait un épisode où Bambi, au lieu de s'égarer dans la forêt, de rencontrer le lapin Panpan, arrive au village des Schtroumpfs.
Voilà, et donc c'est tout le temps du copier-coller. Et alors le plus drôle, c'est la dimension totalement obsessionnelle de son cerveau.
C'est que je pense qu'il a été frappé par une scène que tout le monde connaît, c'est le duel des magiciens dans Merlin l'enchanteur avec Merlin et Madame Mim, où ils se transforment dans une kyrielle d'animaux différents en cinq minutes.
C'est une scène d'une virtuosité fabuleuse.
Il y a ça dans chaque épisode quoi.
Et il est obsédé par les transformations animales. Donc, en fait, il raconte tout le temps la même chose.
Il dit : « Je vais faire un nouveau dessin animé, papa ». Je dis : « OK, très bien ». Et puis après, pouf, un coup de baguette magique, c'est une princesse qui se transforme en cygne, c'est un schtroumpf qui se transforme en cochon.
Ce n'est que ça, que ça. Et il est occupé depuis, mine de rien, ça l'occupe depuis maintenant-- il a vingt-cinq ans, il s'occupe depuis huit ans.
Et donc chaque année, quand-- il en fait, je dirais, à mon avis, il doit faire à peu près cinq dessins animés par an et puis il en choisit un.
Et celui-là, alors, on le sonorise, je trouve des voix d'amis, et je fais moi-même une ou deux voix.
Je fais le Grand Schtroumpf : Partez les petits Schtroumpfs, on va aller chercher de la salsepareille. Voilà. Et je fais des voix.
Il fait des voix aussi ou il fait la voix du narrateur. On choisit la musique ensemble et donc je m'occupe de la bande son avec lui.
Et ça me prend un temps de bénédictin. Voilà. Et donc je sais plus suivre le rythme parce qu'il produit beaucoup plus.
Mon but, in fine, c'est qu'il ait un enregistreur comme celui que tu as aujourd'hui pour faire cette interview,
qu'il puisse le manier lui-même et commencer à lui-même enregistrer les voix qui lui plaît, diriger les voix et arriver presque à faire ce dessin animé de A à Z.
Mais c'est une activité qui le passionne, pas rentable une seule seconde. On me dira non, je veux dire pas professionnel, on me dira : « Mais qu'il aille travailler dans un studio de dessin ».
Il n'ira jamais travailler dans un studio.
Il faut bosser en équipe, ouais.
Ça ne l'intéresse pas. Et puis il ne va avancer que sur les obsessions qui l'excitent. Le reste, après une heure, il va dire : « Ça ne m'intéresse pas ».
Et donc, je disais qu'il n'est pas dans le réel parce qu'il n'a aucun sens de l'argent. Tu lui donnes un billet de cinquante euros, un billet de cinq euros, c'est la même chose.
Et même quand on lui rend l'argent de cinquante euros, il estime qu'il a plus qu'avant parce qu'il a des billets et des pièces, alors qu'avant, il n'avait qu'un billet.
Enfin, tu vois le genre de truc où tu t'arraches les cheveux. Il est de plus en plus autonome. Comme tous, on essaye de leur apprendre l'autonomie, mais il serait incapable de payer une facture, il serait incapable de gérer un budget.
Donc quand tu penses à l'après-
L'après, c'est quand je casse ma pipe, oui.
Ouais. Ça t'angoisse d'y penser ?
Ben c'est pas pour rien qu'il y a--
on a plein de faits divers où on a des vieilles personnes qui vivaient avec leur grand fils handicapé, qui ont essayé de faire flamber leur appartement ou qui les étouffent sous un coussin.
C'est triste à dire, je suis désolé d'être aussi trash.
Non non, c'est tout à fait-
Mais, mais-
C'est important.
Mais il y a eu énormément de cas comme ça où le parent survivant se sentait tellement démuni, tellement abandonné qu'il se dit : « Je vais pas le laisser,
il doit partir avec moi » pour parler poétiquement.
Moi, on n'en est pas là. Sa maman et moi, nous sommes divorcés, mais nous avons des discussions extrêmement constructives à son sujet.
Voilà, mais on n'évoque jamais ça. C'est très embryonnaire hein, parce que autiste Asperger, maintenant, c'est super tendance dans les romans.
Depuis Millénium, on croit qu'ils sont tous Lisbeth Asperger, qu'ils peuvent tous casser des codes informatiques et être le roi, les rois du monde.
C'est-à-dire l'autiste traité dans la fiction, j'ai souvent des envies de meurtre hein, parce qu'il est forcément surdoué et à la fin, c'est forcément une formidable aubaine de l'avoir rencontré.
Et il y a comme ça des films français, mais je t'aime et je suis sorti furieux. Et le distributeur me dit : « Mais enfin, tu sais quand même, ça délivre un message très positif ».
Je dis : « Justement, c'est bien ça le problème ». Ça fait croire que c'est une maladie et pas un handicap. Ça fait croire que c'est curable, qu'il y a un happy end à la fin.
Et là, je dis toujours : « Il n'y a pas de happy end ». Il y a des aménagements, il y a des progrès, mais y a pas de happy end.
Et ça n'enlève rien à tout l'amour qu'on peut avoir pour eux. En attendant, on ne se dira jamais maintenant, il ou elle est tirée d'affaire.
Et ça, je suis désolé d'être aussi négatif. Et c'est pour ça, un jour, j'avais dit dans une émission, j'avais dit en boutade : « Le Christ qui n'a pas dit que des conneries a dit à chaque jour suffit sa peine ».
Ils ont coupé parce que j'avais dit qui n'a pas dit que des conneries. Mais voilà, à chaque jour suffit sa peine et ça, j'y crois ardemment.
Et je n'ai jamais autant vécu l'instant que depuis qu'il est grand, plus autonome. Maintenant, je vis l'instant, je ne fais aucun...
Ben déjà, c'était peut-être moins ma tendance avant, mais-- alors tu me diras : « Comment est-ce que tu te projettes dans dix ans dans le futur ?
Que va devenir ton métier ? Que vas-tu faire après ta retraite ? » Je vais te dire : « Je n'en sais rien ». Moi, le meilleur moment, c'est ce soir quand je vais regarder le soleil qui se couche sur ma terrasse en buvant un verre de blanc.
Voilà, ça, avec la personne que j'aime et c'est tout. Mais tu fais plus de plan de carrière quand tu es parent d'un handicapé.
Déjà, si tu en faisais avant, c'est déjà débile. Aujourd'hui, tu essayes juste de carpe diem.
Oui, je sens que la situation spécifique de ton fils influence très fort tes opinions sur le sujet.
Pour revenir un petit peu sur la question du vocabulaire-
Oui.
Quand j'avais interviewé donc Guillain Majerote, ce grand monsieur qui a la Légion d'honneur, qui fait plein de choses pour les personnes autistes en Belgique.
Il insistait très fort pour dire, et je n'étais pas tout à fait d'accord avec lui : « Surtout, surtout, ne pas dire autiste, ne pas dire personne autiste, dire personne avec autisme ».
Tu ne le rejoins pas vraiment sur-
Non, mais chacun place ses combats où il veut. Moi, mon combat sera plus dire surtout ne jamais dire maladie, mais toujours dire handicap.
Ça, c'est essentiel.
Et à l'inverse, à-
Toujours, parce que maladie, on se dit ça se guérit, un handicap ne se guérit pas.
Et d'autres, alors, pour parler un petit peu de la question du handicap, d'autres disent : « Mais
une personne autiste, quand elle est dans sa chambre toute seule devant son ordinateur, elle est pas en situation de handicap, elle est pas handicapée ».
Donc est-ce que être autiste, c'est être handicapé ou est-ce que c'est parfois être en situation de handicap ?
Non, non, c'est être handicapé. Qu'on arrête de rire. Il est devant un écran de manière totalement obsessionnelle et de manière totalement hors du monde.
On va dire que tout le monde qui est passionné par son boulot, qui est devant un écran, qui regarde une série ou fait du binge watching, non, c'est pas la même chose.
En tout cas, le cerveau des autistes que je connais, ce sont des téléviseurs qui zappent et qui ne s'éteignent jamais.
Pour que mon fils puisse s'endormir, il faut lui donner du Temesta à forte dose, sinon il ne dormira jamais. C'est un cerveau en perpétuel mouvement qui zappe en permanence.
C'est pour ça que la conversation est si difficile. C'est qu'il ne termine pas forcément ses phrases parce qu'il a déjà l'idée suivante.
Il a une quinzaine d'idées récurrentes, ou de peurs ou de phobies qui vont revenir dans la conversation. Non, non, non.
Qu'on arrête de dire que c'est juste pour certains gestes du quotidien. C'est un être au monde qui est différent.
C'est un être au monde qui est totalement différent.
Ça, on est d'accord, oui. C'est-
C'est un être au monde qui est totalement différent, et qui n'est pas dans le concret.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que quand il est devant son écran et qu'il regarde de manière obsessionnelle-
Mais je dis pas qu'il est malheureux pour autant. Je dis simplement-
Voilà, mais je dis justement, est-ce que le handicap n'est pas dans tes globes oculaires à toi, quand tu le regardes et que tu vois une situation de handicap, lui, il est pas malheureux.
Est-ce qu'on peut vraiment dire c'est une situation handicapante ?
Ce qui se passe, c'est qu'il faut en permanence mettre des caoutchoucs au bord des tables.
Oui.
C'est pas une question de le surprotéger, c'est une question de lui mettre des pare-chocs par rapport au réel. Là, heureusement, je veux dire, il a un GSM, il peut m'appeler ou appeler sa mère s'il a un problème.
Dans son portefeuille, il n'a pas des sommes d'argent colossales, il risque pas de se... Mais on lui a déjà volé des choses dans le tram', je dirais.
Il est totalement démuni par rapport à ça, mille fois plus que quelqu'un de normal, qui pourrait à la limite réagir.
On ne sait jamais qui il va rencontrer. Il peut très très bien rencontrer quelqu'un qui va profiter de sa faiblesse, pour l'arnaquer complètement.
Il ne se rendra pas compte qu'il est arnaqué ou beaucoup plus tard. Donc, on est en permanence, quelque part, en état d'alerte.
Moi, j'ai lâché énormément de lest, mais il y a une époque où je le lâchais pendant deux heures, pendant une après-midi dans ce club d'activités avec des trisomiques.
Je stressais pendant les trois heures en me demandant : « Est-ce que, à la limite, il va...
» J'exagère, mais enfin, pas taper sur la gueule, mais à la limite, est-ce qu'il va devenir violent et très très énervé par rapport à un trisomique qui l'énerve ?
Donc entre les trois heures où je ne vivais plus et où je me demandais ce qu'il allait en advenir et les trois heures où quelque part, il est sous ma supervision, je préfère encore qu'il soit sous ma supervision.
On sent quand même que ton expérience de l'autisme Asperger reste un autisme qui a besoin d'une grande assistance, qui a, voilà.
Oui. Moi, je sais qu'il y a des Schovanec et tout ça qui parlent sur NT. Mais pour moi, c'est-- enfin, je n'ai jamais rencontré ce monsieur.
Tant mieux pour lui s'il se débrouille, mais je pense qu'il rend un très très très mauvais service.
Ah bon ?
Oui, je pense qu'il rend un très mauvais service parce que-- c'est-à-dire que c'est du showroom. C'est-- enfin,
c'est pas de sa faute, mais il fait croire que justement, quelque part, l'autisme, c'est presque une chance à l'entendre.
En fait, c'est toute la difficulté. C'est que c'est un spectre, ça existe sur plein de formes différentes.
Oui. Et moi, je pense à des parents qui sont avec des gosses chez eux toute la journée, qui n'arrivent à les caser nulle part.
Moi, j'aurais envie, presque, j'aurais envie de lui casser la gueule. Parce que dire-
D'accord, ok.
Et tous ces bouquins et ces conférenciers, etc. qui disent : « Ah... » et qui commencent. Moi, je ne peux plus les entendre.
J'ai envie de dire : « Allez, venez vivre vingt-quatre heures ou une semaine avec nous et on en reparle ».
Et est-ce que tu n'es pas simplement un petit peu jaloux de ces personnes qui ont un autisme- Plus léger, qui ont moins besoin d'assistance ?
Et quand tu les entends exister, ils ont la légitimité de parler de leur vécu.
Je suis pas jaloux, mais alors qui parlent exclusivement de leur expérience personnelle, mais qui n'apparaissent pas comme dans le jeu des familles, comme : Ah.
C'est l'autiste de démonstration quoi. C'est pour ça que je parlais de showroom. C'est-- Comme il y a l'appartement témoin qui est tout à fait parfait,
où il y a jamais aucun défaut et aucun robinet qui fuit et aucune merde et aucun plafond lézardé.
Et ben ça, c'est quelque part, c'est l'autiste témoin. C'est l'autiste que quelque part, tout le monde accueillerait volontiers chez lui parce que quand même, il est si intéressant et il a un univers tellement personnel à faire partager.
On arrête de rire, l'autisme au quotidien, c'est pas ça. L'autisme au quotidien pendant l'enfance, je peux te dire que moi, ça a été des colères où mon fils se roulait par terre pendant trois quarts d'heure.
Et pour le sortir de sa colère, il fallait une heure pour essayer de trouver la clé, le mot,
le sujet de conversation qui allait peut-être pouvoir l'apaiser et le sortir de ses démons intérieurs et de ses peurs et de ses angoisses.
Non, moi, j'ai traversé, enfin, je dis moi, comme énormément de parents, j'ai pas du tout envie de me mettre en avant là, sur ce terrain-là.
Je veux dire, comme là, je parle parce qu'on parle à deux de ça, mais
comme énormément de parents, j'ai vécu des moments totalement épuisants où le soir, on a juste envie soit de prendre des antidépresseurs, soit de se bourrer la gueule.
Moi, je préfère à la limite prendre une bonne bouteille de Bordeaux pour me détendre en me disant : C'est moins mauvais pour la santé.
Donc en fait, tu es presque énervé que ça s'appelle pareil, qu'on dise l'autisme pour les personnes qui sont en situation où ils ont un grand besoin d'assistance.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une époque où c'était pas du tout diagnostiqué. On disait qu'ils étaient caractériels, qu'ils étaient dyslexiques, qu'ils étaient atypiques.
Et maintenant, on plaque, on met autiste pour énormément de monde, tellement le spectre est large. Et effectivement, c'est différent.
C'est différent d'avoir-
Tous ceux qui le demandent et qui sont en situation, qui sont en détresse, qui ont un besoin d'assistance, en tout cas, oui.
Oui, oui, oui. Mais je dis, il y a pas... Les choses sur clés, je dis pas qu'il y a des autistes imposteurs et des autistes profonds.
Je dis simplement que c'est dangereux et en tout cas, c'est biaisé et ça a des effets secondaires que je trouve merdiques,
de mettre en exergue tel ou tel autiste qui a, entre guillemets, réussi, qui s'en est sorti et de dire : Ça, c'est l'exemple type de l'autiste.
Donc, vous, parents, vous avez un autiste, surtout, ne perdez pas espoir. Il arrive à sûrement être à ce niveau-là un jour.
Alors que c'est le miroir aux alouettes. Il y a très, très peu de chances que-- il y a très, très, très peu d'autistes qui arrivent à s'insérer dans une scolarité normale, à ne pas être dérangé par une chose aussi
a priori basique que le vacarme dans une cour de récréation, qui arrivent à être dans un collège avec des classes avec-- ou dans une école avec des classes de vingt ou vingt-cinq élèves.
Il y a très, très, très peu d'autistes qui arrivent. Je connais un autiste qui était un condisciple de mon fils, qui était passionné d'audiovisuel,
qui a commencé des études, qui est venu faire un stage, qui est venu faire un montage avec moi.
Mais avec toute la bonne volonté du monde, il y est pas arrivé. Il n'y est pas arrivé. Alors que les parents étaient extrêmement supporteurs derrière lui.
Enfin, toutes les conditions étaient réunies. Il y a un moment où ce n'est simplement pas possible. Parce que l'être au monde est différent, parce que le cerveau est configuré différemment, parce que le respect des consignes,
n'est pas possible.
Il y a des autistes qui vont faire un travail absolument mirifique, mais qui vont mettre une semaine pour le faire là où un autre prendra une journée et donc ne sera pas rentable.
Il y a la question de rentabilité. Alors, on lit tous les articles, il y a des autistes qui ont des
facultés formidables en informatique et aucune lassitude par rapport à la répétition et donc qui peuvent aller dans des boîtes informatiques vérifier,
je ne sais pas, telle banque de données ou tel processus.
Ils sont formidables, ils pètent des flammes. Tant mieux. Très bien. Bravo. Mais croire que ça, c'est la norme, non. Non.
Quand on fait passer-- voilà, j'ai été très long, mais quand on fait passer l'exception pour la norme, qu'on dit : C'est à ça qu'il faut arriver et on peut y arriver.
Là, je dis : Achtung, attention, ça, c'est très dangereux.
Mais c'est justement toute la difficulté. Enfin, quand on parle de chiffres, quand on fait des statistiques et qu'on dit : Une personne sur cent cinquante est sur le spectre autistique, etc.
Mais on peut pas de test-
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Sur tout le monde.
C'est pas vraiment. Moi, j'ai personnellement la conviction qu'il y a énormément de ceux qu'on appelle les autistes invisibles.
Dans mon année, quand j'étais à l'école, on devait bien être six sur cent trente.
C'est la grosse difficulté de ce handicap, c'est qu'un trisomique, quelque part, ça se voit immédiatement, c'est lisible, c'est accompagné depuis des années.
On a le mode d'emploi. On a le mode d'emploi, on sait grosso modo ce qu'il faut faire. Il y a une grande compétence et une grande habitude par rapport à cet handicap.
L'autiste, d'abord, ça se voit pas sur la tête. C'est parfois à travers la façon de marcher, à travers le regard, surtout à travers l'élocution qui peut être extrêmement
monotone et monocorde, à travers le vocabulaire employé parce qu'ils peuvent parler comme des dictionnaires.
Et donc ce sont tous les sym-
C'est un monologue, c'est un dialogue souvent.
Voilà, ce sont des monologues. Quand il dit : On va discuter. Non, il discute pas, c'est un monologue et on fait : Ah oui, ah, oh oh, ah oui, bien sûr.
Et alors, il est très content, il a l'impression qu'il a discuté. Bon, mettons, tout ça, ce sont des symptômes qui ne sont pas immédiatement identifiables.
Donc c'est pour ça que non seulement ça reste difficile à diagnostiquer, mais ça reste socialement difficile à accepter parce que
le plus frappant, franchement, il faut aller à cette école où il n'y a que des autistes Asperger.
C'est absolument fascinant parce qu'à la cour de récré, parfois, ils sont tous à tourner chacun autour d'eux-mêmes, mais absolument à rien faire de collectif.
C'est très très impressionnant à voir. Et là, effectivement, là, on a l'impression d'être dans un film de science-fiction, d'être dans le village de Darnay de John Carpenter, où il y a tous ces enfants blonds qui ont un regard bizarre.
Et là, on a l'impression de dire : OK, là, j'ai une sorte de vision. L'autisme,
il y a un spectre très très différent, mais en même temps, on voit tous que quelque part, un fil invisible les relie parce qu'ils ont tous cette attitude qui est
quelque part à côté quoi.
Pour parler vulgairement, on a l'impression que ce garçon est à côté de ses pompes.
Et bien, c'est vraiment ça. Mais un type qui est à côté de ses pompes, mais vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre, forcément, je considère que c'est un handicap qui nécessite un solide accompagnement. Voilà.
Oui. Et donc je retiens que tu as
un léger malaise, une des difficultés avec le fait de ne pas rappeler à chaque fois que quand on parle des autismes légers, des personnes autistes qui s'en sortent plutôt bien dans la vie,
tu aimerais qu'on rappelle à chaque fois qu'il y a de très nombreuses personnes qui ne sont pas dans cette situation-là.
Je suis agacé par tout discours positif et angélique, de toute façon, de nos jours. C'est quelque chose que je ne supporte pas.
Mon tempérament est beaucoup plus noir et réaliste. Et l'espèce de... c'est pas du politiquement correct, mais une espèce d'obligation comme ça aujourd'hui de délivrer des messages positifs.
Et ce film est formidable parce qu'il délivre un message positif. Non, un film n'est pas formidable parce qu'il délivre un message positif.
Un film est formidable parce qu'il est bien joué, bien écrit, bien réalisé et qu'il propose des images de cinéma.
Un film ne se réduit jamais à son message. Et aujourd'hui, il y a trop d'amalgames de dire parce qu'un film ou une œuvre d'art, c'est quand même si positif et ça fait du bien.
Attendez, une œuvre d'art n'a jamais été un médicament. Une œuvre d'art est là pour questionner le monde, pour poser des bonnes questions et pas forcément poser de réponses.
Mais là, ça vient de mes études de philosophie. Je préfère une question bien posée qu'une mauvaise réponse vite faite. Voilà, donc c'est la question qui est passionnante.
La réponse, il y a généralement, si la question est passionnante, il y a mille réponses. Mais les films qui délient, les bouquins qui délivrent une sorte de prêt-à-penser avec,
oh, les trucs du style : « Soyez vous-même et soyez vrai » et les coachings.
Je n'en peux plus. Ça m'insupporte cette espèce de, oui, de prêt-à-penser new age assorti d'une petite vapeur essentielle de, de, de...
Ah non, non. Pitié, au secours, au secours, au secours.
Et donc, dans le cadre de l'autisme, ça se voit comment ? Ça s'applique comment, ça ? Tu trouves que les Joseph Schovanec qui vont à la radio-
Mais je peux pas le... J'ai pas envie de faire son procès, je ne l'écoute pas. Je sais pas ce qu'il raconte.
C'est peut-être un type très bien.
À qui tu penses alors quand tu parles de discours positif ?
Mais non... moi, ce que je vois, je te disais, je vois ça dans les fictions. J'ai vu un film avec ce crétin de Ducret, le grand comédien qui joue dans...
C'est quoi ? C'est Fais pas ci, fais pas ça. Enfin, un comédien de télévision et il joue un grand entraîneur qui... égoïste, qui ne pense qu'à lui et qui doit garder pendant une semaine un garçon autiste de douze ans.
Et le garçon révolutionne sa vie, est une vraie chance. Il devient tout de suite beaucoup moins-
Oui, mais c'est con. Enfin, voilà.
Oui, oui, mais c'est con, mais on a tout le temps ce, dans le truc. Virginie Efira a joué un film avec, aussi avec un adulte, un acteur de la Comédie française dont le nom m'échappe, qui jouait un autiste Asperger.
Très bien d'ailleurs, mais à la fin, on a l'impression qu'ils allaient partir ensemble dans le soleil couchant, quoi.
C'était... Non, il n'y a pas, y a pas ce genre de happy end. Et ça, c'est de plus en plus fréquent.
Il y avait eu historiquement, là... mais là, c'était carrément un cas de télévision, un épisode de l'Instit avec ce crétin de Gérard Klein, qui arrivait.
Il y avait un autiste dans la classe. En une heure et demie de téléfilm, la question était réglée. Le gosse allait beaucoup mieux à la fin
et ce formidable instit pouvait repartir dans une autre classe régler un autre problème.
Et c'était insultant. C'était carrément insultant. C'était d'un mauvais goût puantissime. Voilà, et là, effectivement, j'ai tendance à perdre mon calme parce que,
voilà, il y a aujourd'hui une espèce...
Bon, on sait bien qu'on est dans une époque anxiogène et difficile, mais alors, à côté de ça, quand on a des espèces de prometteurs de bonheur qui disent : « Mais pensez plus à vous et trouvez des moments où vous vous retrouvez.
» Envie d'une bonne paire de claques et... Non, non. Les solutions, il faut les trouver soi-même. Il faut les trouver avec un travail sur soi-même, mais pas avec des prometteurs de beaux jours.
Non, non. J'ai fait quatre ans de philo, ça m'a apporté énormément de bonnes questions, mais je ne ferai jamais des stages de coaching et des machins et des...
Ah. Non, non.
Très bien.
Non, j'ai un énorme respect pour les grands psychiatres ou les grands psychologues, mais pas ces espèces de... Le terme coach, déjà, me donne...
Des coachings de vie pour des gens qui sont en merde et qui ne trouvent pas de sens à leur vie.
Oui, oui. Reste chez moi avec une plaque Life coach.
Oui.
J'ai jamais très bien compris ce que c'était.
Voilà. C'est ça. C'est ça. Mais on déborde, là.
Oui, mais donc on a... On a parlé en long et en large de, voilà, l'industrie du cinéma et de l'autisme.
Moi, je peux te dire, j'ai perdu mon père à seize ans. Ma mère n'avait pas fait d'études. Elle m'a dit : « Écoute, je n'y connais rien.
Simplement, je sais que tu as toujours fait ce que tu as pu. Fais ce que tu peux, donne le maximum, mais je te fais confiance.
» C'est la plus belle phrase que je pouvais entendre. J'avais simplement quelqu'un qui me faisait confiance, qui n'a jamais été un coach, qui ne m'a jamais donné des conseils.
Mais simplement, voilà, faire confiance, dire : « On est là. » Voilà, c'est des trucs fondamentaux, existentiellement viscéraux de...
C'est tout. Et puis après ça, vaya con Dios, je me suis démerdé comme j'ai pu. J'ai fait des erreurs de déguillage comme tout le monde.
J'ai appris de mes erreurs. Et puis j'ai réussi à effectivement faire ce job que j'aime et faire partager ma passion à beaucoup de monde.
Moi, je peux dire que si on me demande dans dix ans à quoi j'ai servi,
je dirais juste : « Mais si j'ai pas donné du bonheur, mais simplement parfois ouvrir les yeux, aiguiller la curiosité de spectateurs ou d'auditeurs.
» Quand j'ai un type qui me croise dans la rue, qui me dit : « Ah merci, grâce à vous, j'ai été voir ça.
Ça m'a accompagné. J'aurais jamais été le voir tout seul. Là, je me dis mission accomplie. Là, j'ai servi à quelque chose.
Dans ma modeste partie, je sauve pas des vies comme un chirurgien. J'ai pas un métier essentiel, mais si je peux avoir donné...
Si à travers le podcast de cinq heures, toutes les semaines, on donne deux heures de,
de plaisir à des gens qui parfois ont des existences un peu difficiles où ils ont pas beaucoup l'occasion de s'échapper vers l'imaginaire, vers la fiction, tant mieux.
Très bien. Voilà, mais c'est tout, hein. Modestement, c'est vraiment tout.
Mais je dirai jamais : j'ai réussi ma vie parce que j'ai une belle voiture, j'ai pas de voiture, j'ai une belle voiture, j'ai une maison, j'ai un berger allemand et j'ai des vacances en avion.
Non, non, ça, je-
C'est pas ta quête.
C'est pas du tout, du tout mon rayon. Voilà, moi, je suis dans le relationnel. C'est pas pour rien que je travaille dans un service public.
J'y tiens énormément. Voilà, pour moi, l'information est un service. C'est pas une marchandise, c'est pas quelque chose qui se monnaye.
On allume sa radio, on allume télévision, pouf, on a quelqu'un qui vous aiguille. Voilà, je vais pas aller plus loin dans la politique, mais voilà, je trouve que les services, avoir des services publics forts,
pertinents, efficaces et qui fonctionnent, ça, c'est
un grand, grand, grand plus pour la société en règle générale.
Y compris, évidemment, naturellement, dans le domaine du handicap. Et je vais d'ailleurs être provocant jusqu'au bout. Visiblement, j'étais fort provoqué avec les autistes qui disent que tout va bien, mais je trouve que
justement, il y a tellement de handicaps divers et variés dans la société dans laquelle on vit.
Il y a tellement de vies difficiles que je pense que
des opérations comme Cap48, c'est très très bien. Bien sûr, c'est très généreux, mais je vois absolument pas pourquoi c'est le citoyen qui doit se substituer au pouvoir public pour régler ses problèmes.
A priori, on devrait, avec la société dans laquelle on vit, on devrait avoir un enseignement de qualité et des services médicaux.
Enfin, médicaux, ils sont déjà très bien, mais ce type de solidarité envers les handicapés,
voilà, je crois pas que c'est le citoyen qui, chaque année, doit mettre la main au portefeuille et signer un chèque pour que ça fonctionne, parce que le citoyen, il paye déjà des impôts toute l'année.
Voilà, donc ma philosophie est la suivante. Voilà, maintenant, je ne parlerai pas de parti politique précis ni quoi que ce soit.
La difficulté aussi, c'est que... on en a parlé dans l'épisode avec le Suza, mais donc très peu de psychiatres sont formés sur l'autisme, très peu de médecins sont formés sur l'autisme, très peu de pédagogues sont formés là-dessus.
Donc on veut bien payer des gens. Il y a certainement, certainement un ministre qui veut bien payer des gens, mais est-ce que les gens sont disponibles ?
Est-ce que les gens sont-
C'est un vaste problème que nous n'allons pas résoudre dans un podcast, aussi long soit-il.
Yes. Mais Hugues, merci beaucoup. On a un petit peu débordé, mais c'est parce que les sujets étaient parfaitement passionnants, hein, l'autisme et le cinéma.
Euh, je te remercie d'avoir passé ces septante minutes avec moi.
À bientôt.
Et on se retrouve dans deux semaines.
C'est un peu mensonger, ce titre de Septante Minutes Avec.
Il y aura du montage, hein. On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode. Au revoir. Un tout grand merci à toi, Hugues, pour le temps qu'on a passé ensemble.
Le plaisir était total. Si vous découvrez ce podcast aujourd'hui, eh bien, d'abord, merci d'avoir écouté. Il y a une vingtaine d'autres épisodes qui sont disponibles, dont certains avec d'autres personnalités de la RTBF, comme par exemple
Myriam Leroy, Rudy Léonet ou Alain Gerlache.
Donc foncez, c'est gratuit et vous ne le regretterez pas. J'ai mis le lien pour ça dans la description de cet épisode. Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux et ça m'encourage très fort pour la suite.
J'ai aussi mis les liens vers le Facebook et le Twitter dans la description, donc pensez à aller suivre Septante Minutes Avec là-bas.
J'adore lire vos messages, donc n'hésitez pas à m'écrire, ça me touche toujours très fort. Quelques annonces avant de se quitter.
D'abord, Fanny Ruwet, la maman de notre réseau, vient de lancer son nouveau podcast. Ça s'appelle Les gens qui doutent.
C'est des interviews de gens qui doutent. C'est mélancolique, mais pas glauque. C'est même plutôt drôle à écouter. Elle a déjà publié deux épisodes avec, par exemple, Kyan Khojandi, donc le mec de Bref, et avec Eva Bester de France Inter.
C'est différent de ce que je fais ici, mais c'est assez complémentaire. Donc, si ça vous tente, allez écouter ça. J'ai aussi mis le lien dans la description.
Voilà pour la première annonce. Deuxième chose, si vous habitez à Bruxelles et que vous êtes une femme, je serai invité à un event la semaine prochaine à la gare Centrale, le vendredi 24 mai.
C'est un event qui est non mixte et donc réservé aux femmes, sauf pour le speaker, du coup, et je serai pas le seul.
Et je ferai une présentation pour expliquer pourquoi en Belgique, encore plus qu'ailleurs, il y a très très peu de femmes dans le secteur informatique.
C'est gratuit et ça promet d'être super fun. Donc si ça vous intéresse, j'ai aussi mis le lien dans la description pour s'inscrire, ainsi que le lien vers l'article que j'avais écrit à ce sujet il y a quelques mois.
Enfin, on a pas mal parlé d'autisme dans cet épisode-ci et aussi dans l'épisode qu'on avait fait avec le Suza il y a un mois.
Et que ce soit en parlant avec deux cliniciens experts en la matière ou aujourd'hui avec Hugues, qui est papa d'un garçon dont l'autisme est relativement important.
Dans un cas comme dans l'autre, le focus s'était mis plutôt sur un segment particulier de l'autisme, sur les personnes dont l'autisme est, je dirais, très handicapant et très visible.
Vous l'avez entendu quand on a parlé avec Hugues, il y a souvent beaucoup d'ambiguïté quand on parle de l'autisme, puisque ça existe sous de nombreuses formes.
J'ai bien pris note de son insistance pour que surtout, on n'invisibilise pas les personnes comme son fils, qui, voilà, sont moins aptes à en parler, par exemple, sur le plateau télé.
Mais à côté de ça, ça me semblait essentiel de montrer que les autistes, entre guillemets, invisibles, enfin, ils sont nombreux et même plus nombreux qu'on ne le pense.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi d'inviter une femme qui est directement concernée pour montrer que l'autisme, c'est ça aussi.
Cette femme, c'est Julie Dachez, une rockstar dans le milieu de l'autisme en France et je suis super content de la recevoir.
Elle a publié deux livres à ce sujet que j'ai juste adorés et dévorés. Joseph Schovanec a d'ailleurs écrit la préface de son dernier livre.
C'est le monsieur dont Hugues voulait casser la figure. Voilà, voilà. Julie n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche et comme tous les autistes, elle dit ce qu'elle pense.
Et je suis impatient de la recevoir puisque, comme presque toutes les femmes que j'ai reçues dans ce podcast, que ce soit, voilà, Charlotte Belhière, Émilie Marie,
Myriam Leroy ou Nadia Geerts, Julie est très émancipée et elle remet beaucoup de choses en question.
Ça promet d'être très intéressant et ce sera dans deux semaines. Et puis, seulement une semaine après ça, il y aura un méga triple épisode spécial
pour les élections fédérales, européennes et régionales ici en Belgique, où je recevrai trois politiciens, Ecolo, PS et Open Vld.
Et on débriefera aussi le résultat avec Frédéric Chardon, qui est journaliste politique à La Libre Belgique. Encore merci de l'avoir écouté et je vous dis à très bientôt.